what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
fans are still freaking out over that
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness trailer
we should tell him the truth
rightfully so it was probably one of the
best trailers that i've seen and of
course and i can't believe they did this
but they've already teased patrick
stewart returning as professor xavier
along with the illuminati as well whose
members are probably other major huge
cameos that we can't wait to see and
what this trailer really did show us is
that anything is literally going to be
possible in this movie we knew that
going into it but now they've shown us
we have a maria rambo captain marvel a
superior iron man and the ultron bots
that he controls different variants of
strange and of wanda including zombie
variants of the both of them and an
animated world that they're going to
visit as well signs that peggy carter is
going to show up as captain carter and
deadpool is going to show up as well so
the big question is who else can we
expect to see and this is the big and
exciting question so let's talk about it
and if you're new be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so let's just go ahead and talk
about who we really want to see more
than anyone and that is hugh jackman's
wolverine now here's the thing i've
talked to my buddies in the community
paul at heavy spoilers greg over at the
real rejects chris of course at cosmic
culture and i've seen the new rockstars
take on this as well we all agree
unanimously that this is professor
xavier it is no doubt his voice in the
trailer not to mention the character
rolls up doesn't kind of walk up and the
silhouette in the back of his head does
look to be bald and most of the internet
agrees as well and can tell this is
professor xavier not to mention there
have been some rumors coming out before
this and this just confirms that so this
is professor xavier and his voice was
patrick stewart now he might not be the
variant of professor x that we are all
expecting but i'll come back to that in
just a bit what i really want to talk
about is his conversation with marvel
studios and then to the press that he
had that made everybody believe that he
was not going to come back as professor
xavier because the same thing has
happened with hugh jackman now i just
want to clarify i'm not saying that he
is definitely going to be in the movie i
am just saying that now it is definitely
possible before this trailer came out
everybody was saying that patrick
stewart or hugh jackman were not going
to be in the film because they have both
said that they are done with the
characters they have retired their
characters they said goodbye and logan
both of them did but look at where we
are now patrick stewart has returned so
clearly whatever kevin feige and the
people at marvel studios pitched patrick
stewart was incredible and very very
convincing for patrick stewart to return
and reprise a role that he considered
was officially done and if patrick
agreed to come back that might convince
you to come back as well plus not to
mention it seems like it's pretty much
confirmed that ryan reynolds is going to
be coming back as deadpool we believe we
spotted him on the poster and he posted
a picture on his facebook of him in the
deadpool suit yesterday plus rob
liefield the creator of deadpool
severely hinted that deadpool is indeed
in that poster and in the film yesterday
when he tweeted three sh faces when
comicbook.com posted their article
saying that deadpool is possibly spotted
in the newest poster for doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness now this is
funny on two accounts because one it's
like he is kind of confirming it but two
the face that deadpool is making is the
sh face in the poster and then rob
liefeld tweeted again stating there is
no photoshop just windows to the
multiverse stating that nobody
photoshopped this trailer and put
deadpool in it but the glass pieces are
just windows into the multiverse and
deadpool is in one of the glass pieces
and this is coming right from rob
liefeld the creator of deadpool himself
so you have patrick stewart who agreed
to come back after he said he's never
coming back you have ryan reynolds
coming into this movie as deadpool who
is hugh jackman's best friend their
relationship is hilarious but there is
some leeway here for hugh jackman to
return two amazing actors and great
friends of his are returning in this
film and it's possible that they could
drag him along if he's saying no perhaps
they could change his mind perhaps he
could do a quick cameo as wolverine i'm
not saying that he's going to be a part
of the illuminati but it's clear that
they're going to be exploring a bunch of
different universes in this movie so
whether hugh jackman pops out of a
portal and just appears in our universe
as wolverine for a brief second or maybe
not even as wolverine maybe just himself
maybe they don't show the claws maybe he
just appears says something and he's
gone much like the cameo where he says
go f yourself to professor xavier and
magneto or maybe professor x kind of
shows a brief background of what
happened in his universe and while we
see that little clip at play of
everything that played out we could see
the other x-men and wolverine could be
one of them again i'm not saying that
it's going to happen but it's now a
pretty decent possibility now in regards
to exactly who we are seeing here i do
not believe it's the exact characters
that we've seen in the fox x-men movies
i think they're going to be variants
because that was kind of the whole point
of patrick stewart and hugh jackman
saying goodbye to their characters they
didn't want to bring them back they
didn't want to undo their deaths but
this way with the multiverse they don't
have to they can play the same
characters but be completely different
because they can be from a completely
different universe and that is what i
believe that we are seeing here i think
we're seeing a professor x who is going
to be possibly the strongest version of
professor x that we've ever seen and a
few jackman showed up as well i think
it's going to be a different logan that
we saw in logan and the other fox x-men
movies this way their deaths are still
there and whatever universe we saw the
fox universe that all happened it all
took place they're dead there and i've
heard a lot of people stating that maybe
we'll get a professor x that didn't
actually get shot and hit in the spine
and maybe he's not in a wheelchair and
this certainly is an interesting idea
however what i think about when i hear
this is absolute point in time we
learned about absolute points in time in
marvel's what if how these points in
time can't be changed and if they are
the universe essentially gets destroyed
and i'm thinking that professor x being
in a wheelchair might be some type of an
absolute point it's kind of like uncle
ben dyne or aunt may dying now basically
an aunt or uncle of peter parker dying
kind of like an absolute point there but
perhaps professor xavier being shot in
the spine is an absolute point in time
because if you look very closely in the
trailer when the character kind of comes
up and says we should tell him the truth
you can see that the character doesn't
walk up it's not the movement of
somebody walking it's very very smooth
it is somebody rolling up not to mention
there are six chairs noticed in this
scene for the illuminati but there is a
gap in the middle this gap is most
likely meant for professor xavier to
roll his wheelchair up there and that's
where he sits and if this is true that
means there are actually seven members
of the illuminati now of course we all
have our theories about who it could be
black panther mr fantastic captain
carter maria rambo who is captain marvel
in her universe black bolt superior iron
man balder the brave there's a ton of
possibilities that all would be
absolutely epic and who knows maybe
wolverine is one of those members but
i'm assuming that if he is going to be
in this movie if hugh jackman is
returning it's going to be for a quick
little cameo but no doubt we are going
to be getting some epic cameos when we
see those members of the illuminati who
do you think these members are going to
be right now i think the only one that i
know for sure to be in the film that i
don't have any doubt about is mr
fantastic and of course obviously
professor x but drop your illuminati
lineup down below and remember there
could be seven of them not six that
space in the middle is clearly meant for
professor xavier and his wheelchair so
drop your seven down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the recent news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof